after two movies a Christmas special and
a bunch of other MCU appearances there
is plenty of backstory for fans to know
before going in to see Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. if something left you
wondering what you missed here's what to
know warning spoilers ahead
between the events of Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 2 and volume 3 the
ever-growing and changing team has done
plenty in other MCU stories they were
near the center of the action and
Avengers Infinity war and Avengers end
game and they appeared briefly at the
beginning of Thor 11 Thunder the average
MCU fan likely kept up with those films
and the important plot and character
developments therein but what's less
certain is that everyone who bought a
ticket for volume 3 will have seen the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
which started streaming on Disney Plus
in November 2022 the 42-minute special
which was in essence and extended Kevin
Bacon joke contains two critical pieces
of information in advance of the third
cinematic installment for one mantis
reveals that she's Peter Quill's
half-sister mantis
it's the greatest Christmas gift I could
ever get
also sometime prior to the events of the
holiday special the Guardians took
nowhere off of the collector's hands in
the first movie the inhabited head of a
deceased Celestial is described as a
lawless place of ill repute where one
should watch their wallet later Thanos
all but destroys nowhere in his effort
to claim the reality Stone during the
holiday special and the start of volume
3 the Guardians of the Galaxy spend
their days guarding and rebuilding
nowhere which has become a refuge of
sorts that they're creating their own
utopian society for broken people and a
broken place is in keeping with the
movie's themes especially when compared
to the high evolutionaries disturbing
concept of utopia
the mcu's timeline has gotten
increasingly convoluted especially in
the post-blip era despite the fact that
most of the franchise's stories are told
in a pretty straightforward way volume 3
relies more than usual on a framing
device that flashes back and forth
between Rocket's youth as a captive of
the high evolutionary and as present in
which he's fighting for his life this
structure definitely tugs at the
heartstrings and the story is well told
enough to follow but exactly when
everything is happening and for how long
is less clear there are visual markers
that let us know some time has passed we
first see rocket as a kid then a
juvenile the high evolutionary has only
one tiny silver device on his face as
opposed to an entire apparatus
stretching it taut viewers first saw
rocket in the mcu's version of 2014.
when the first Guardians movie took
place volume 3 takes place after the
holiday special which is set around
Christmas of 2025. raccoons mature over
one to two years so we can guess that
rocket is at least 13 but he's probably
much older he brags that he's escaped
prison on 22 separate occasions which
wouldn't happen overnight real raccoons
can lift to about 16 but his genetic and
cybernetic enhancements have almost
certainly given him a longer lifespan
as volume 3 begins Peter Quill is still
reeling from the loss of the Gamora he
loved nebula is doing her best to
support him through his grief which is
why she fails to mention that the
version of her sister who is now in the
MCU is her contact within the ravagers
whether this Gamora is Peter's Gamora is
played for light humor and heartbreaking
drama and volume 3 but it can also leave
some fans who don't recall the
convoluted way we got here scratching
their heads a great many of Marvel's
face 3 4 and 5 arcs have to do with
alternate timelines universes Realms or
Dimensions Doctor Strange for example
met the Illuminati a group of supers
from Universe 838 this Gamora isn't from
an alternate universe per se but she's
not from star-lord's timeline the Gamora
that loved Peter was thrown from a cliff
on vormir during Infinity War so that
Thanos could obtain the Soul Stone she's
definitely dead tell me you didn't do it
yeah endgame created a new timeline
branch and with it a Divergent Gamora
with unique life experiences and
personality traits biologically she's
the same being he fell in love with but
she has totally different memories while
some comic stories would refer to this
alternate timeline as a different
universe that doesn't seem to be the
case here the MCU is often purposely
vague about these distinctions though so
as to keep as many story possibilities
as open as possible
the goldthwed race known as The
Sovereign is introduced near the
beginning of volume 2 when Star-Lord and
Company are hired to protect their Uber
valuable annulax batteries they're
successful which wins them the esteem of
The Sovereign a notoriously haughty
people rocket destroys any good will the
Guardians have with the Sovereign almost
immediately though when he Pockets a few
anulax batteries in addition to their
payment nebula Volume 2 ends with five
post-credit scenes the third shows that
high priestess Aisha has something
cooking a next-gen birthing pod she says
she's designed him to destroy the
Guardians after they wronged and
embarrassed her she adds that she'll
call him Adam which fans correctly took
to mean that Adam warlock's arrival was
imminent volume 3 gives Adam's backstory
as well as the rest of the Sovereign a
tweak the high evolutionary brought them
into existence as one of his experiments
aimed at creating a perfect race though
Volume 2 makes it seem like Adam was
Aisha's idea she complains that the high
evolutionary took him out of his cocoon
too early this retcon doesn't come out
of nowhere
that my child
is the next step in our Evolution and
it's worth noting that while The
Sovereign are an MCU invention the high
evolutionary Aisha and Adam Warlock are
long-standing Marvel Comics characters
who definitely matter in each other's
stories totally unremarked upon in
volume 3 is the gem be set in Adam's
forehead canonically it's the Soul Stone
like Marvel Comics the MCU is loaded
with unusual celestial bodies volume 1
had the floating decapitated head that
is nowhere and volume 2 boasted ego The
Living Planet Now volume 3 presents a
cosmic Mass unlike anything we've ever
seen before the orgoscope is an organic
bioengineered entity grown owned and
operated by the high evolutionary and is
public-facing company orgocorp it's
literally a planet-sized chunk of tissue
that houses orgo corpse headquarters
where the company's daily operations
take place and where proprietary
information like say Rocket's file is
kept secure that's sensitive
intellectual property is guarded by
orgocentris one of whom is Nathan
Fillion's frustrated Foreman Master
karja less weird but less well explained
is orgo Corp itself volume 3 only
devotes a line or two to the idea that
the high evolutionary is the nefarious
CEO of a shady conglomerate Orca Corp
seems to be offering naturally derived
body modifications to Consumers
throughout the Universe there's an
element of greenwashing to it all though
since we know the high evolutionary is
also experimenting with cybernetics and
has a terrifyingly warped moral compass
orgocorps less controversial work covers
4 and pays for the High evolutionaries
real passion callously creating and
destroying life until it fits its ideals
it took 26 movies for two characters to
get intimate on screen in the MCU and
even then what was advertised as a
steamy Marvel first turned out to be
rather underwhelming the most enduring
romance was between a witch and an
Android second place probably goes to
Peter Quill and Gamora and we only got a
few minutes worth of their relationship
at the very end of volume 2 and in
Avengers Infinity War fans likely went
into volume 3 wondering whether the MCU
might engineer a way for Star-Lord and
Alternate timeline Gamora to find love
but instead director James Gunn took
this potential subplot and what seems to
be an entirely unexpected direction if
you're looking for it there's major
romantic tension between Star-Lord and
nebula throughout volume 3. Gamora
herself picks up on it after which
there's a moment when quill seems to
realize he does find Nebula attractive
nebula is of course hard shelled and
combative as ever knock it off what
never noticed how black your eyes were
but her empathetic attitude toward him
early on combined with the closure Peter
gets when he says goodbye to Gamora
leads us to wonder are we supposed to be
shipping Star-Lord and nebula Now volume
3 is ambiguous enough to support the
idea
when Drax mantis and nebula get stuck on
the high evolutionaries pyramid-shaped
vessel they discover an onboard prison
full of fair-haired children mantis and
nebula struggle to communicate with the
scared kids but Drax who comforts them
by badly imitating a monkey eventually
reveals that he speaks their language
after Peter manages to save rocket the
guardian's mission becomes rescuing the
Innocents trapped on that ship the film
never provides the name of their race or
a planet from which they might hail but
two Clues help to fill in the blanks in
one the high evolutionary watches a
blonde girl runs circles in a
human-sized hamster wheel he's annoyed
that while he's been able to engineer
negative qualities out of her he hasn't
been able to replicate Rocket's Superior
intellect since the high evolutionaries
methods seems to be capturing specimens
and rapidly evolving them or breeding
them through birthing pods these
children are basically the high
evolutionaries latest guinea pigs in the
mid-credit Stinger the girl who was
jogging around the hamster wheel has
joined the new iteration of the
Guardians led by Rocket Raccoon the
others refer to her as phyla this is
almost definitely Marvel Comics by
Lavelle a genetically engineered
superhumanoid and the daughter of Marvel
who does eventually join the Guardians
of the Galaxy
superhero movies usually have
over-the-top fights that would
absolutely prove fatal to normal people
but volume 3 takes this idea to the
extreme because it's advertised as the
finale of the Guardians Trilogy and
because the trailers impressed Horrors
seem to foreshadow some tissue-worthy
tragedy most fans fully expected a fan
favorite protagonist would die instead
volume 3 contains multiple fake out
deaths but no main character kicks the
bucket are you ready
for One Last Ride Rocket's near-death
experience is not only plausible but it
also serves as the Catalyst for the
whole plot Drax takes two deadly blasts
to the chest but manages to recover
seemingly thanks to the same Med packs
that wouldn't work on Rocket but Groot
is decapitated in a duel with Adam
Warlock on nowhere after which The
Sovereign takes nebula's comically large
energy blade to the chest and collapses
lifeless and quill succumbs to the
elements in space how did they live
through that it's easy enough to explain
with Groot he has sped up regenerative
Powers especially as they pertain to his
limbs since he wasn't completely Droid
he simply had to regrow the plant matter
that makes up his body and he remained
the same grew which wasn't the case
after volume 1 the mcu's Adam Warlock
has Superior durability and healing in
the comics he can be killed but can't
actually die at the end of the movie he
imparts this ability to Peter who really
was a goner to bring him back to life
volume 3 was meant to be the Capstone to
these superhero shared story and based
on all the tearful goodbyes in the
film's final moments it probably is at
least as a group Gamora returns to the
ravagers and her smile makes it clear
that's where she belongs mantis goes off
to find herself and Drax adopts the
children that had been the captive
subjects of the high evolutionary the
actors who play those characters Zoe
Saldana palm clementieff and Dave
Batista have indicated they're unlikely
to return to the MCU but the mid-credit
Stinger teases a new guardian's team
moving forward led by rocket and made up
of Groot Cosmo craglin Adam Warlock and
phyla whether we ever actually see this
team in action is yet to be determined
but at least in fans imaginations
they're out there guarding the Galaxy
for his part Peter Quill returns to
Earth to reconcile with his grandfather
Jason curiously there's a tacked on
title card that reads the legendary
Star-Lord will return that seems to
indicate Chris Pratt will be reprising
the role with Gunn having migrated to DC
the future of the Guardians franchise is
up in the air but star our Lord is a
marquee MCU character and Pratt is a
bankable star since he's back on his
home planet it's possible we'll see him
again in a standalone film or in a cameo
in another Heroes film but it's just as
possible that he'll retake to space to
play a part in The Avengers movies
slated to Premiere in 2025 and 2026.
foreign
[Music]